[Music]
all right we're back let's go to my
hometown h town and talk to fred what's
up fred how are you doing
hey doing good thanks for talking to me
that's real exciting you got it brother
it's exciting for me too what's up
well um i'll try to be a coherent here
um
you're on the wrong show if you want to
be killed right yeah wrong show anyway
yeah by uh anyway my relationship with
my spouse has kind of
it's devolved into
basically what i feel is abuse and you
know emotional and you know
mental abuse and i started reacting by
lashing out physically and not at her
but you know at our house and i'll punch
holes and things and
throw objects and why do you do that
that's a it seems like a strange choice
why do you choose right
i i don't know it's a i guess it's a
it's a poor way of
i feel like if i don't hit something
else i'm going to hit someone i guess
and
it's a false choice
i suppose so yeah it is absolutely false
from this point who who taught you that
did your old man do that did your mom do
that no no my my dad was the calmest
person on the planet my mom was very
very you know she was physically and
verbally abusive but she never she never
punched holes in anything but
um so here's the deal i don't know
never again
got it
yes uh-huh
say it
never again will i
lash out physically at anyone or
anything done we're good
yeah i hope so yeah every time you're
about to hit a wall here's what i want
you to think
hey mom
i got your anger and your rage
and i am going to show you how tough i
am even though it's gonna cost me my
marriage i want you just to think that
before you hit something
okay okay
yeah
cool
all right so that was not even why you
called but
um
or here's here's a simpler way right
before you hit something ask yourself
why am i choosing to hit this
because if you can choose to hit it then
you can choose not to
yeah that's absolutely right right like
why am i choosing i do that all the time
dude like why am i choosing to tail this
guy who just cut me off what a what a
dumb why am i choosing to eat this i
know it's not gonna make me feel good
like what am i doing and i mean so i'm
i'm there with you but when i start
when i take ownership of what's
happening and i use ownership language
in my relationships things change my
behaviors change all right so your
marriage is devolving you've got a an
emotionally abusive wife
you're choosing to act like a
five-year-old and then what
well
i guess
i feel like we're both kind of at that
point where
it feels like it feels like
the marriage and the family is slipping
out of our hands are you done no no no
no no they don't slip out of your hands
you're letting them go
are y'all are you done
yeah i don't want to be no certainly not
i i absolutely love my wife and i love
my family and uh you know you got little
ones too oh yeah yeah we got a
two-year-old and a uh nine-month-old um
and then she's got a stepson or i've got
a stepson that's from her previous
marriage who is six
um they're they're awesome um
hey
again
we'll get to why you called eventually i
don't even know why you called yeah i
keep interrupting you
that stuff i said earlier about not ever
hitting anything ever again
you got little kids in the house brother
no i never never again
got it
oh absolutely do not pass this on to
them
don't teach them that this is the way
grown-ups handle their frustration
they deserve better than that fair
yeah absolutely cool and i would tell
the same thing to your wife don't
emotionally abuse your husband don't
yell and scream and say mean things to
people
ever you're not worth that she's worth
more than that but also don't
demonstrate to kids this is what adult
relationships look like because then
they take that crap to school with them
and then so goes our country right
okay so why aren't you quite you call
man i keep interrupting you well no
honestly i don't know if i if i know why
i just i i i'm so lost i don't know what
to do does your wife want a divorce
no i don't i don't think so
she brings up well let's just divorce
them all the time and you know when
there's a fight
sounds like she might want to get
divorced
well i i
she says a lot of stuff and and i don't
know i mean i think so is she a liar
she's not trustworthy
well i mean
sounds like she's being really clear
with you
let's just get a divorce then maybe a
hint that she wants to get a divorce
is it that you don't want to see that
come to fruition
oh man i definitely don't and then and
maybe that's maybe i just have blinders
on i just i feel like in my heart she
doesn't because
once we once we finally screw our heads
on tight and actually talk to each other
like adults were able to
say wow i was so stupid and i'm so sorry
and
let's not do this again but then it
happens again um
and i don't know how to break out of
this cycle and i certainly hope she
doesn't want a divorce
maybe she does but i i definitely i
don't want to lose her i don't want to
lose that time with my kids it's so
precious to me um here here's here's
what i
um there's very real moments
involving yelling
involving emotional abuse involving
physical abuse
when i would recommend a 30-day
separation everybody's got it someone's
got to go get an apartment get a hotel
and we gotta let everything calm down
because the volatility in your marriage
the volatility with your kids it creates
a cyclone that is almost impossible to
get out of until there's some sort of
physical break
yeah
and i don't want a i'm not telling you
get divorced i'm saying somebody's got
to step out and say i'm gonna let this
thing breathe for a second
because this this dynamic this dance has
to stop
right
okay
somebody's gotta turn the lights on and
say what are we doing and you can't keep
dancing like this and then apologizing
and dancing again because the apologies
don't mean anything anymore
yeah
and you've got an abusive household and
you've got three kids in it not gonna do
that have you all gone to see a marriage
counselor
yeah we're actually seeing one right now
and she is absolutely amazing um
we're seeing her tomorrow like you know
maybe it's the type of thing where
things get will get worse before they
get better i don't know but it's just uh
you know
um
so what is she recommending
well she's not really recommending
anything she's we're just she's
we've been like to three sessions or
something
she's just recommending we identify the
identify what these
what is the core emotion i guess
eft i don't know if you're familiar but
yes i am so
back up
all of that before you start digging
into core emotions and pass but
say i will never talk to you that way
ever again
i will never punch a hole through all
ever again
you have to stop abusive behaviors
before you start getting into core
issues and feelings and all that crap
yeah okay
you have to stop the abuse
right because here's why you can't get
into core issues if you haven't dealt
with the
abusive behavior because the core issue
is what sets off the abuse of behavior
so reverse engineer it
yeah
stop setting fires and then figure out
why do i always want to set fires
and so the whole thing starts with a
contract and
um
i've got several colleagues across the
country that do this all the time
relational contracts
i agree to never cuss at you again to
raise my voice at you again and if i
feel like it's about to happen instead
of choosing to raise my voice at you i
will choose to go for a walk and you
will let me go and then when i come back
i will choose to engage in a
conversation with you and the choice
language is important because we feel
like i just couldn't help it bullcrap we
can
we can and if we can't help it in the
moment we can help it five minutes
before if we came up at five minutes
before we can help it ten minutes before
an hour before two hours before
yeah
right
yeah it's like people who drink coffee
at eight
eight pm at dinner and then they have to
take you know some kind of crazy
medicine to go to sleep at night
right the inability to sleep started
with choices made a long time ago so
you
have a contract that you all signed to
say i will not hit another thing
because right now your wife doesn't feel
safe and you don't feel safe right right
oh yeah and we've said as much to each
other okay so there's a lot of i don't
feel safe and yeah
we're struggling so much to get to that
safe point we've had points where we
still felt safe i just don't know how to
get back there here's how you say what
does safe look like
safe is you don't yell at me
because when you yell at me it reminds
me of my mom ever my five-year-old
little boy comes out to protect me
and then i act like a five-year-old by
throwing things and hitting things and
saying things that i wish i hadn't said
and she says whenever you don't do
whatever or you're not whatever
i lash out because i learned that some i
saw that
behavior modeled through some system i
was a part of
and i turn into a seven-year-old and act
like a seven-year-old doing a temper
tantrum
i won't do that anymore and when i feel
it coming i will call it out
it's gonna sound so cheesy bro you gotta
practice she's got to practice okay yeah
if you've
ever been like in like whenever i do was
do it in mma we do kickboxing sparring
there's always one idiot when
everybody's sparring everybody's going
70 there's always one idiot going 110.
and it always causes problems and it
turns into a whole thing there's always
one [ __ ] in the gym doing that
and yeah
we have to say we are going to practice
i'm not going to go 110.
when i feel myself leaning into these
things that we're going to agree what
safety is in my how in our house we're
going to agree with safety looks like
and then we're going to practice it
and then when everybody feels safe
then you can do sophisticated things
like dealing with core issues
and dealing with feelings and dealing
with past trauma then you can own your
story but until you
are safe man you can't own nothing
because your body's just trying to
survive
is that right
oh yeah man yeah that is resonating with
me uh big time so here's the here's your
steps okay
i want you to take your wife out and say
we're gonna have a like a good
conversation together no fights no
nothing
like let's have a good talk
and then i want you to take a piece of
paper or a fancy notebook whatever you
want and say
i want us to talk about what does it
feel like to be safe what does safe look
like for us paint a picture of it man
crystal clear
safe doesn't look and it's not going to
be like when you do this i don't feel
safe nope
yeah that's how it goes right no no what
a safe looks like you and me sitting on
the couch just watching tv
safe looks like you and me going to the
gym together safe looks like you and me
going out to dinner we got babysitter
for the three kids
and then let's make that happen well
then how do we feel good sitting on the
couch together well the house is picked
up and you always drop your crap
everywhere or that you help with you
help with bed bedtime with the kids
and then i can relax finally that's how
you reverse engineer these things you
start with a picture and then you work
backwards
okay
all right
and then i want you to take this
agreement to your counselor and say hey
we did some work on our own
and we agreed
we're going to stop these behaviors that
make the other person feel unsafe we're
going to practice them
and then the counselor's going to be
like oh my gosh i'm a great counselor
and you can be like nope i called some
idiot on the radio for free
thanks
and then y'all can do the hard trauma
work and i'm not dismissing feeling work
it's important i'm not dismissing core
issue work that stuff's all good but you
can't address those things in the middle
of a fire
yeah it's like trying to decide like why
it's so hot and you're
and you're standing in the middle of an
inferno get out of the fire first and
then we can have the cool philosophical
physics discussions or whatever you know
okay
hey can i tell you something brother
yeah
you're worth not being angry all the
time
life is super cool when you're not angry
all the time
it's just that's just peaceful man you
just laugh
or when you're sad you just get to be
sad but you don't be sad and get raged
and kids you got what six or four or
two-year-old
yeah
or sorry a six a six or two and an um
not an adult that's right so i don't
know how to say this in a nice way but
the season you're in right now sucks
it's hard
yeah
it's super fun man i love hugging babies
and i admit i got a five-year-old i love
it love it love it
and there's a lot of diapers and a lot
of crying and a lot of can i have a
snack can i have a snack and not very
much sex and connection and intimacy
a lot of
exhaustion i ringing the bell
oh my gosh yeah yes
so you're also in the middle of winter
and you found yourself out in the front
yard with no jacket it's just cold it
sucks right now spring's coming
go get a jacket on man go be safe in
this season okay
okay
can you do that well yeah
yeah i think so um i no no
can you do that
i absolutely can do yes you can you can
do whatever you want to you're from
houston man
cali you can bang on trash cans for all
i care that was an astros joke i hope
that was good dude you can do whatever
you want man
you can you can you can you gotta own
your past you've done this crap and now
you gotta say okay now what now what's
next
what's it gonna look like what's the
future gonna look like we get to decide
we're gonna start with being safe
they're gonna go from there
same team we're good
yeah 100 okay so here's the thing yeah i
want you i want you to holler at me
after you take your wife out and i want
you to go to a nice place
go to somewhere nice
take your wife out somewhere nice have
this safety conversation
and if it gets hot if she starts it say
no no
no no fights no fights
and if she wants to fight say okay cool
let's we're going to this another time
let's just enjoy your dinner
and we'll talk about what's a picture of
safety look like and let's reverse
engineer it and if she points out things
about you that you're falling short just
take it
own it
don't fight it own it
and then bring that stuff to your
counselor keep working keep working
you're in the right path keep working
and don't forget you're in a crappy
season
it's a lot of little kids man it does
get better
be brave my brother we'll be right back
on the dr john delaney show